you know chef is a movie that explores
both the negative and positive sides of
social media how much of that came from
your own experiences well you know I
think our generation is the generation
that remembers life before Twitter and
now sees the world and what's changed
after it and we've seen a lot of good
things happen and we've seen a lot of
people make their lives very complicated
and every time and I've been on Twitter
for about five years so I'm very careful
every time I get on there and I'm you
know there's often cautionary tales
about what happens if you're too
emotional had too much to drink
think you're being funny or sarcastic
it's just there's a whole different
language that I think our kids
generation understands better than we do
right and you sometimes pay the price
for a negative tweet but in the case of
your film chef there have been so many
positive tweets a lot of momentum I mean
shoutouts from Anthony Bourdain and Elon
Musk and Dane Cook and Larry King Joe
Jonas the list goes on what does that do
for a small film like this well that
this is a bit of an experiment to see if
social media really has as much
relevance as as the marketplace seems to
think right now traditional marketing
where you just dump hundreds of millions
of dollars into commercials still seems
to rule the day and you see these huge
weekend's that are dictated by very big
marketing machines and I've and I've
been on the other side of this I've been
part of that you know a film that has
had that kind of push behind it but the
question now becomes can a word-of-mouth
film that's well reviewed and touches a
specific audience and touches them in a
very sincere way without a big marketing
push behind it without one billboard can
the word of mouth spread thanks to
social media and what's happening is
this film is bubbled up from from two
cities to 270 screens to 500 screens and
now over a thousand screens and this is
all thanks to social media I know you
encouraged Robert Downey to join Twitter
and that has sparked some fun tweets
from the set of The New Avengers film
when it comes to using social media
what's the difference between how it
ends up being used for a film like chef
and how it gets used by big studios well
I think big studios the it's just a
little bit of it's like nuts on top of a
sundae I mean it would it's fine to have
it but it would work
without it to film like chef or a pop-up
restaurant or a food truck or an art
gallery opening or a stand-up comedian
those that size of an audience and the
independent film world really is
impacted by social media a peer-to-peer
recommendation holds a lot more weight
than a commercial that tells you how
great a movie is well speaking of peers
we mentioned Elon Musk he's a friend
obviously in the case of the Iron Man
film he was part of the inspiration for
the Tony Stark character just out of
curiosity is he is he an investor and
chef he's not an investor a chef but
he's a guy that I've become friends with
through the course of working on Iron
Man Iron Man 2 we actually filmed at
SpaceX which nobody really heard about
yet now it's a now everybody knows about
SpaceX but if you look at Iron Man 2
Justin hammers evil weapons factory was
with SpaceX completely Tesla also is an
example of a company that has benefited
from social media all the positive press
surrounding them has enabled them to for
example avoid doing things like doing
their own TV spots I would love to know
if you would ever have any interest in
directing a TV commercial for Tesla it's
on for Tesla yeah I'm a Tesla driver I
signed up I put my name on the list
because Elon was a friend and he was
nice enough to let us film at his
factory for free he did a cameo for us
and I said oh he's making a car let me
sign up for his little car let me let me
make the guy feel good and then I was
one of the first people to get one and
it turned out to be Car of the Year it's
amazing I sold my other car I thought it
would be like a second car and I haven't
looked back it's an amazing product and
I would definitely do a I would
definitely not just endorse it here as a
consumer but also I would do a
commercial for him any day I think it's
changing the industry in a good way well
speaking of new technology right now we
know there is a push in Hollywood to get
FAA approval for the use of drones in
productions and films what do you think
about all that what do you think about
drones and films the use of technology
to help to help he said safe is is a
good thing so whether it's having a
digital Dumble a digital double for a
very dangerous stunt
not putting a human in harm's way or if
you could eliminate the use of
helicopters in precarious situation and
replace it with a very controlled
situation with a remote-control vehicle
I think it could be good I think it's
worth exploring radio-controlled drone
especially as the technology gets better
is something that could be used in place
of that and allow for much more dynamic
filmmaking so I think it's definitely
worth controlling your career
progression and part is because of the
different things that you learned on the
different films that you've done and and
you've got chef right now but you're
going to be moving right back to a big
production with Disney's The Jungle Book
what are some of the things that you
have even learned on this project on
chef that you can take with you to your
next project I realize how much fun I
had and how much the audience seems to
enjoy what my tastes are and the things
that make me laugh and make me feel good
I'm seeing in the audience's that they
feel good too
and when you go through a studio
development process it's very very easy
to lose track of that it becomes a big
committee it becomes a lot of people if
you really speak from the heart and do
something really wonderful and sincere I
think it's refreshing in the marketplace
and and if you could it's nice to carry
that sensibility into the big movies and
I think when we made Iron Man just the
cast that we put together and the and
the tone of that film was the same tone
I would use in the independent film and
the same type of comedy I would use the
same type of casting and the tone of
Iron Man ended up being something that
although offbeat was successful and now
there's a whole Marvel Universe that's
consistent with what we did on the first
film so I guess that the lesson I take
away is don't lose your sense of
instinct don't lose your gut sense of
what plays and what doesn't and don't
rely on statistical analysis or a big
machine to compile data to help inform
your your creative process it's great
insight one final question a
little-known jon favreau fact before
your film career you worked at Bear
Sterns
brief yes what was that like well I was
facilities planning so I wasn't it
wasn't like I was running around with my
yellow tie yelling buy buy sell sell I
was the guy if your air conditioner
wasn't working you'd call my department
and I'd run over and and tell everybody
it's gonna it
gonna get fixed immediately it was an
interesting moment though it was the
time when it Bear Stearns was moving
from 55 Water Street up to 245 Park and
so it what the industry was moving from
Wall Street up to the banking center and
it was it was a bit of a transitional
period and I was there actually for the
crash so I got to see I got a really
good bird's-eye view that definitely
felt a little bit eerie and familiar
when I was doing wolf of Wall Street
last year and it was set the beginning
of the film was set in that time period
and I remember distinctly what it felt
like